you Indian right now get the [__] out of
here nobody cares about that [__] how do
you know these guys man
they hung out with you times are
different man I grew up in the 90s that
wasn't happening you're on the wrestling
team or something
I knew it I [__] knew it though this
is your lady unless you guys are single
huh where is she
gonna take a field trip to cheat on your
man you know what I mean your girlfriend
is too just a girls trip to Miami that's
the dick capital of America oh let's see
what's going on with these guys are you
nervous right you nervous
oh he just texted his girl what happened
in the text hold up did you get my snap
check the Snap Yo no she meant to send
that to somebody else God [__] somebody
else tonight ladies if you ever wanted
to date a minority but not really
[Applause]
thank you